have you ever dreamt of a crossover
between rocket League and fasten the
Furious because I definitely have and
now our dreams are coming true with the
latest rocket league DLC I'm Matt and
this GameSpot news update lives its life
a quarter mile at a time thankfully this
mashup DLC is not an April Fool's joke
the $2 add-on pack introduces the ice
charger vehicle which is based on
Dominic Toretto's iconic dodge charger
from the movies on top of that it's
joined by an exclusive set of wheels and
six premium decals
this definitely isn't rocket leagues
last DLC packs so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to be the first to learn about
all of your car soccer news The Fast and
the Furious add-on pack is slated to
release for ps4 Xbox one and PC on April
4th just 10 days before the fate of the
Furious hits theaters it's not the first
time a videogame has done a mash-up with
the brand either just a couple years ago
the Forza horizon 2 team released a
standalone version of its game that
featured vehicles from the film's you
can see all of those cars right here on
our channel and if you want even more
vehicle action check out our video where
we take the Nomad for a cruise in Mass
Effect Andromeda
[Music]